leave it to the women of the view to
identify the worst part of balenciaga's
child porn referencing little kid
featuring
BDSM photo spread that the luxury
fashion house published last week
according to Alyssa Griffin who is
supposedly the Republican on that show
the worst part of the fashion Line's
depiction of a frowning little girl
holding a teddy bear in s m gear
featured along with a handbag ad
highlighting a major Supreme Court
decision on child pornography the worst
part of course
is that it gave those mean nasty
conservatives an opportunity to pounce
what's going on I filmed this ad
Champion particularly distasteful um in
this moment so there's this there's
growing anti-lgbtq sentiment right now
and it how it's Being Framed is as
portraying you know trans people as
groomers this is a terminal here on the
far right they're groomers this is where
you get the anti-drag queen stuff that
we're seeing so Balenciaga played right
into their hands by having kids in a
sexualized manner carrying something
that represents you know sex acts I
think it was a really bad misstep at a
moment where it's just kind of a
dangerous time to even give Credence to
those kind of insane takes yeah I mean
we can't even show the picture because
it's so distasteful
damn you Balenciaga your portrayal of
quote kids in a sexualized manner
carrying something that you know
represents sex acts her words not mine
is playing directly into the far right
hands what a misstep now we're going to
have to hear more of those insane
right-wing takes that just so happen to
accurately describe what powerful people
are doing before our very eyes I'm
Michael knows this the Michael Knowles
show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from redneck beard
who says Whoa man don't knock the
Christmas music do you put up all your
Christmas decorations and then take them
down the same day too
no I don't redneck beard
because
not only is Christmas not a month-long
event that occurs in December it's
called Advent that's that's what happens
during December
Christmas also is not just one day it's
just amazing how it's not your fault
redneck beard this is a misconception in
the culture but it drives me crazy
because we don't have any of the the
right timing for anything anymore and we
want to rush everything so we want to
celebrate Christmas before Thanksgiving
in some cases and everybody wants to
celebrate Christmas right after
Thanksgiving all the way through
December and then they want to stop
celebrating Christmas on December 26th
Christmas is a season Christmas is 12
days that's why we have the song The 12
Days of Christmas that's why we have the
play 12th night 12th night by
Shakespeare which refers to the end of
that Christmas season on on the eve of
epiphany and then you celebrate the
Epiphany and then we go on and then
there's more and then you celebrate
Easter at Easter and you celebrate the
4th of July at the 4th of July and you
celebrate Christmas
on Christmas okay
drives me crazy and then you do that
enough and that's your whole life and
then you die and before you die you need
a will which is why you got to check out
epic will right now go to epicwell.com
use promo code Knowles if you're
listening to this show odds are that you
put a lot of stock into how you raise
your kids you understand that your
children look to you to Define how they
view the world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will determines how your financial
assets are dispersed as well as your
personal property it lays out your
Healthcare power of attorney to ensure
that your end of life decisions are
carried out if you're just starting out
and you don't have thousands of dollars
to spend on an attorney but you want to
make sure your savings your belongings
and your family are all protected you
have to create your will at epicwill.com
today epic Will's earliest Day plans
start at just 119 dollars you can save
10 when you use promo code Knowles go to
epicwill.com
promo code Knowles save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package that is
epicwill.com promo code nulls
k-n-o-w-l-e-s make sure that your assets
and your home and most importantly your
kids are protected epicwell.com promo
code Knowles the that that reaction from
The View
it tickled me so much
the the problem with the Balenciaga
Kitty porn campaign is just
how the Republicans will react oh you
gave those Republicans an opportunity it
reminded me of this Norm McDonnell joke
I actually think that the view which is
perfect because because Norm had this
sort of long and troubled history with
the view with the show and they they
were enacting this Norm Macdonald joke
where Norm one time he was describing
the real problem if terrorists were able
to get a dirty bomb and kill millions of
people
I can't say my friend's name but he said
his biggest fear
is
that Isis or some terrorist group like
that would get a hold of a dirty bomb
and exploded over a major city within
the United States
and kill
tens of millions of people
because then
the blowback against
innocent Muslims would be absolutely
terrible
yeah that's that's right that's true
okay let's do some jokes
he's the love Norm's guest s there she
doesn't
white seemed to she's degrades she goes
yes yeah no that would be yeah you know
like if these terrorists
killed tens of millions of people you
know
that the worst part would be the
blowback the islamophobia when the worst
part of the child porn campaign from the
high-end luxury fashion house is of
course the blowback that we see from
those Republicans right no I think the I
think the worst part call me crazy I
think the worst part of the weird child
porn campaign from Balenciaga is the
weird child porn stuff
you know and I I don't think I'm even
using that word hyperbolically
it's the children are clothed at least
that's good but they're there frowning
holding the weird s m teddy bear and
then in the associated game was a
separate ad campaign but it was still
being featured by Balenciaga at the same
time you see a a reference to a Supreme
Court case about child pornography the
odds of this happening coincidentally
are
zero or zero okay I think that's the
worst part I think the Republican
reaction pretty good actually I'm pretty
glad there's a republican reaction to
call attention to this sick sick stuff
you know it's not a nothing Burger the
libs are going to try to say oh no it's
nothing oh come on you conspiracy
theorists you're overreacting uh I don't
think so look at the reaction to the
reaction from Balenciaga
Balenciaga just wiped their Instagram
page
okay if this were just nothing
don't you think Balenciaga would just
sort of move on oh no big deal they
wiped their Instagram page they've
issued
a major apology that's not the only
thing that's featured on their Instagram
page and here's what they say
the first campaign
the gift collection campaign featured
children with plush bear bags dressed in
what some have labeled BDSM inspired
outfits
just put a pause there it's not what
some have labeled BDSM outfits it's it's
BDSM outfits I don't know how else you
would describe it
would you say they're dressed up like
Cowboys no are they dressed up like
bikers no
they're wearing like weird leather chain
stuff but it's clearly a weird sex thing
our plush bear bags in the gift
collection should not have been featured
with children
this was a wrong choice by Balenciaga
combined with our failure in assessing
and validating images the responsibility
for this lies with Balenciaga alone okay
so they are saying
they're they're trying to weasel out of
it a little in the beginning some have
called to the BDSM thing but then
they're saying look this was terrible
this was terrible this shouldn't have
featured kids we shouldn't let this go
through we're sorry it's our fault we're
sorry we're sorry we're sorry
so I don't want to hear oh you you
conservatives are blowing this out of
proportion Balenciaga admits this is a
weird creepy
pornographic child featuring s m having
weird sex thing but then they go on they
say the second
separate campaign for spring 2023 that's
the one with the child porn case being
featured which was meant to replicate a
business office environment included a
photo with a page in the background from
a Supreme Court ruling United States
versus Williams 2008 which confirms as
illegal and not protected by freedom of
speech the promotion of child
pornography all the items included in
this shooting were provided by Third
parties that confirmed in writing that
these props were fake office documents
they turned out to be real legal papers
most likely coming from the filming of a
television drama the inclusion of these
unapproved documents was the result of
Reckless negligence for which Balenciaga
has filed a complaint we take full
responsibility
accountability for a lack of oversight
and control of the documents in the
background and we could have done things
differently okay
I don't buy it
I don't buy it I always want to give
people the benefit of the doubt I I
strive to cultivate a spirit of Charity
and always seeing the bright side of
things sorry I don't think so once it's
a fluke
twice it's a coincidence three things
four things five things I don't know it
just seems a little bit weird
and we are seeing
lots and lots of evidence that
Balenciaga and the people around
Balenciaga
have a weird fascination with weird sex
stuff and kids
okay I'm just noticing that I'm just
seeing that
and we've got a lot of evidence to back
it up you're telling me Oh oops actually
yeah just as we're getting all this heat
for a weird pornographic child featuring
campaign
oh just oops coincidentally the set
decorator use these documents it's
probably from a television uh drama
probably we're not going to give you any
evidence of that but you know let's just
say it's that and it just coincidentally
that the exact part that's featured
there specifically refers to a child
porn case
and yes it's from that notice they say
it's from US versus Williams which was a
case that said that the peddling of
child porn is not protected speech but
in the in the line of that document that
was featured specifically in the
photograph
it referred to a different Supreme Court
decision it was the the Free Speech
Coalition case which actually found that
simulated child pornography is protected
speech
which is a ridiculous ruling from the
Supreme Court but the ruling it was
referenced there was a pro-child porn
case
balenciaga's argument is oh this was all
just accidental
let me tell you something if you most
people have never spent time around a
film set or a photo shoot Etc
nothing is accidental
on a film set on a photo shoot set
especially when we're talking about a
very prestigious very high-end fashion
brand
it's it's not like you walk up there
with a you know a digital camera and say
Okay click click click okay we got our
shots everything is meticulously said
and when you start pulling on this
thread it gets really really weird
because one of the big stylists for
Balenciaga a woman named Lada volkova
got a lot of press yesterday not from
the corrupt establishment media but just
from citizen journalists just from
regular old people who were looking into
just poking a little bit into the
Balenciaga story and the stuff they
found
well I'll let you judge for yourself
I don't see any way to read This Woman's
Work as anything less than an obsession
with sexualizing little kids in the most
perverse egregious nauseating sort of
way
this stuff is enough to keep people up
at night if you don't want to stay up at
night you got to check out Helix right
now head on over to helixsleep.com
Knowles with everything going on in the
world right now you could use a good
night's sleep that is why you got to
check out Helix mattress I've had my
Helix for what two three years now I
continue to absolutely adore it Helix
has several different mattress models to
choose from soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down mattresses for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains even
a helix plus mattress for plus sized
sleepers are you nervous about buying a
mattress online you do not have to be
Helix has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
want to buy a mattress made for somebody
else okay I've got my mattress get out
of my bed I'm a married man get your own
mattress go to helixsleep.com Knowles
take that two-minute sleep quiz find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type mattress will come right to your
door for free plus Helix has a 10 year
warranty and you get to try that for 100
nights risk-free they will even pick it
up for you if you don't love it but with
Helix you will love it it's got over 12
000 five-star reviews the financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never a moment away for a limited time
the LX is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners best offer yet hurry on
over to helixsleep.com
so Lada volkova this is a stylist a very
prominent stylist
worked with valenciaga for a long time
worked alongside balenciaga's creative
director debna vasalia until 2017.
and people started looking into some of
her other work yesterday so Balenciaga
tries to get ahead of the story they say
a lot of volkova has not worked with
Balenciaga or its team since 2017 she is
in no way participated in the Brand's
recent Instagram or advertising
campaigns that's what valenciaga
spokesman told Newsweek okay but this
woman did work with Balenciaga for a
long time she clearly has had a lot of
influence on the company so Jake Shield
who's a former UFC fighter just starts
looking into her Instagram page
we've blurred out the faces obviously
these faces were not blurred out on her
Instagram
well the first ones that pops up is this
little girl in a kind of really done up
sort of hairdo lying on the on the
ground lying on her side in a sort of
skimpy little leotard
and and kind of smiling in a very creepy
way but with a handout that sort of says
no another one is a child in high heels
topless in a very strange sort of
position
obviously a kind of sexualized way you
can see that from the stiletto heels but
not quite showing the face
another one is a child's bedroom just
covered in Gore and blood everywhere
another one is a little teddy bear tied
up in a sort of dungeon or jail cell or
something like that there's more it
wasn't just these four photos
let's see yeah so then there's another
one of people tied up in like kind of
weird plastic trash bags all tied up in
a weird looks very like some kind of
torture scene another one of a little
kid holding up a skull another one of a
little kid being duct taped and tied to
a chair being made to watch something
we're not exactly sure what the kids
being made to watch it another one of
someone with with
entrails pouring out of the the
midsection
and there's more images
so then there's an image on on this
Instagram of just a satanic scene of a
pentagram with a devil demon looking
person up there and then a kind of
sacrifice on another pentagram so now
we're talking about overt overt satanic
imagery
and then we're seeing lots and lots of
teddy bears throughout this person's
campaign this is this is a lot of a lot
of volkova this woman clearly has a
fascination with teddy bears now why
does she have a fascination with teddy
bears well maybe it's just totally
innocent because teddy bears are really
cute and fun and plushy everyone had a
teddy bear as a kid fewer people have
teddy bears as adults but it's her kind
of lying around with teddy bears walking
around with tapers and then there's one
of a teddy bear doing a sexual act
that's really really weird so all of
this I'm not sitting here telling you
that this woman is
some kind of witch you know controlling
the Balenciaga campaign
not telling you she's not I mean there's
a vert satanic imagery here and weird
child sex stuff but then something
that's really really weird I'm not the
first person to discover this someone
called my attention to it and I looked
it up tried it myself
I don't know how to explain this I'm not
making any allegation I'm just observing
this okay I'm just noticing
you type into Google translate Latin to
English
so Latin
the universal language right it's
supposed to be the main language of the
world it's the language that when I
attend Mass that's the language that
it's in but it's the language that was
the universal language until very very
recently
you type in ba
from Latin into English you get nothing
just says ba ba because ba is not a
Latin word then you type in a second
word Len ba Len what's the English
rendering ba Len because Len is not a
Latin word either balenci
violin C again you just get bottle and C
because there's no Latin translation of
that because those are not Latin words
but here's where it gets really weird
you type in ba Len C Aga
and then the English translation is do
what you want
I'm not making any accusation I'm not
even speculating I just don't
do what you want the thing that's really
weird about that is
do what you want is the Commandment of
the satanists this was the Commandment
of Aleister Crowley do what thou Wilt is
the entirety of the law that's what he
says that is that is the satanic
commandment going back to the Garden of
Eden do what you want Eve come on you
shall be as gods do do what you want
now when you look on Google Translate
it says would you like to translate this
from hausa which is some African
language but it's not translating it
from housing that's not what it means in
housing when you click the translator
from house it gives you a different
translation
I I have no way of making any sense of
this
other than to observe
that there's something weird about
Balenciaga and we know it's not just a
coincidence and we know it's not just
the Republican reaction the the pouncing
because balenciaga's taking this very
seriously Balenciaga is wiping their
Instagram page
apologizing immediately for the campaign
taking legal action against the people
who are creating the campaign
and then you look into it and it's
it's just all this
overtly satanic imagery
you can't write off this stuff as a
crazy conspiracy theory you certainly
can't in a world post Jeffrey Epstein
okay
because post Jeffrey Epstein we know
that there actually is an elite cabal of
pedophiles who who have a whole island
who would go to the island and do weird
sex stuff with kids that you can't just
say well you crazy tin foil High
conspiracies we know that happened there
are court documents about it
and yet we still don't really know who
the clients are we still don't have the
little black book no one's really been
held accountable for it Jeffrey Epstein
got Jeffrey Epstein
Gillian Maxwell is getting some sort of
sweetheart deal but what about the
clients
and why why does it always seem to come
down to weird
satanic stuff
you notice this now you might say well
this this designer woman for Balenciaga
she's just ironically
worshiping the devil and putting up all
this imagery the the fact that Google
translate I assume someone just went in
and kind of tinkered with it it's a kind
of weird joke I don't know how else to
make sense of that translation
to and to make it the satanic
commandment that's maybe it's just a
kind of a weird ironic joke or so I
don't but the thing is you can't worship
the devil ironically
you can't do anything ironically for too
long if you do if you if you behave in
an ironic way for your whole life then
it's just sincere then it's just Earnest
that's just what you have done
and when you worship Satan ironically
when you just sort of do what you want
that's a lot of the satanists say they
say we don't really believe in the devil
we just do what we want
right that that is worshiping the devil
that is it it's that line from I think
it was baudelaire it says the finest
trick of the devil is to convince you
that he does not
exist
but he does now speaking of fashion
lines and the devil
Canada right now there's a Canadian
clothing company Simons which is running
an ad campaign marketing its products
with suicide
last breaths are sacred when I imagine
my final days I see bubbles
I see the ocean I see music
even now as I seek help to end my life
there is still so much Beauty you just
have to be brave enough to see it
[Music]
certainly the most perverse ad I've ever
seen since Balenciaga but it's up there
it's the same thing in Canada now
they're saying hey as you plan to end
your life as you get ready to kill
yourself buy these clothes clothes can
still be beautiful
there's still Beauty out there but
you're going to kill yourself but before
you kill yourself give us your money
buy buy our clothes
it's really now why are they doing this
because Canada right now
is passing assisted suicide legislation
Canada is making it legal this is
following a Canadian Supreme Court
decision that discovered some right to
kill yourself and to have doctors help
you kill yourself uh now you are seeing
this expand
and the expansion of what they call
medically assisted
uh
medically assisted something and suicide
I don't know they call it maid
they're expanding this not just to
people who have two weeks to live
because of some grave illness at the age
of 87.
which is always how assisted suicide is
sold oh it's just for people who are on
death's door and they're in intense pain
and we're going to pretend that we don't
have any pain medication and we're going
to pretend that we know exactly when
people will die even though we don't
so it's just a way to be compassionate
merciful
but that's not what's happening
in Canada now they are expanding as
always happens with assisted suicide
they're expanding that to the mentally
ill they're just going to kill the
mentally ill no different than people
have been doing for many years going
back not just to the Nazis but all the
way back to ancient Greece when really
callous cultures would look at the
weakest members and just kill them or
people suffering from PTSD you got a
veteran who comes back who serves this
country and he comes back and he's got
some problems instead of giving that guy
help we're just going to kill him even
children even children with certain
defects in Canada just just going to be
killed off because of this law
and what it gets to is in not just the
absolute perversity obviously it's evil
and perverse and we can castigate it all
day long but what it gets to is a
complete misunderstanding of what
of what a good death is the way she
talks about it in the end she says as I
prepare as I get ready to breathe we're
gonna have a good death With Dignity
it's gonna be a good death it's a
complete inversion of what our culture
has considered to be a good death for
the entire history of and the entire
height of our civilization if we can
look past the horror of assisted suicide
for a second the fact that these
Canadians these really nice oh you know
these nice Canadians up there in
America's Top Hat are going to start
killing the mentally ill and children
with problems and Veterans with PTSD and
Grandma who feels that she's not wanted
anymore and they're just going to kill
all these people
if we can look past the the horror and
the outrage for a second and just look
where is this coming from
what's what it's coming from is an
inversion of our traditional concept of
a good death
it has been traditional to pray for a
good death in our culture and buy a good
death what people have meant in our
Christian civilization is a death that
you are aware of you know that death is
coming not suicide that's always
prohibited that's an expression of
Despair which is a grave mortal sin
but of a good death you know you know
you feel the end is coming and you can
get your soul in order that's why that
was considered to be a good death so you
could get right with God go have
confession die in a state of grace and
go enjoy your lord and savior forever
the purpose of life to know God and to
enjoy him to serve him on Earth and to
enjoy him forever in heaven
that concept of a good death has now
been inverted if you asked people what's
a good death how do you hope to die you
don't you know what they'll tell you and
I'm tempted to say this too sometimes
when I forget about eternal things oh I
want it to be fast oh I don't want to
know it's coming I just want someone to
turn the lights off that's what people
pray for
quick painless unexpected that's the
best death of all
because no thought is given to One Soul
because people mock the idea of the Soul
because people mock the idea of Heaven
because people now believe in our
culture that when you die you just take
a dirt nap and turn to turn to worm food
so the inversion of the idea of a good
death derives from where well it derives
from the inversion of the idea of a good
life
traditionally a good life
was understood to mean a virtuous life
this is how people understood it even in
the pre-christian times
even before
we even before Pagan cultures had much
of an understanding of the Bible and of
the Hebrew conception of God
you at least would have people say a
good life is when one practices the
virtues lives in a manner that is in
accordance with the virtues and
excellence and heroism and then you die
right
then you have the
Christian view and and the pre-christian
view prefigured by the Israelites in the
Old Testament which is we serve God we
we our purpose in life is to serve God
and this involves
loving God above all things and loving
your neighbor as yourself and
sacrificing and
having charity and love for your fellow
man and no greater love has a man than
to die for his friends and and all of
those sorts of things self-sacrifice
today
our view of a good life is exactly the
opposite not only of the Christian view
not only of the Old Testament view of
The Virtuous Pagan View today our
version of the good life is you know you
just have pleasure
you do whatever you want it's actually
to uh quote the Google translate
rendering of Balenciaga from Latin
allegedly is do do whatever you want do
what that will shall be the entirety of
the law
you're not happy in your marriage we'll
leave your spouse life is short YOLO
carpe diem
oh you've got to be happy just be it'll
be so much happier you don't like your
job just quit it
you don't like your family just ditch
them
come on just do whatever you want don't
have kids oh kids are such an [ __ ]
get a dog you'll get some companionship
but you always give a dog away if you
don't like the dog don't have any firm
attachments don't don't involve yourself
in any sort of obligation certainly
don't serve your country ask not what
you can do for your country but what
your country can do for you that's the
modern conception of a good life
and it's tempting because we think that
if we satisfy our most immediate and
base Pleasures that we will be happy but
anyone who has ever done that knows it
doesn't make you happy
it and it doesn't make you free it just
makes you a slave either you can be a
slave to God
a slave to Virtue or you could be a
slave to sin and to your basis Passions
but you're going to be a Slave
if you if all you do let's say you
really like booze and so all you do is
you just drink all day long
you're going to be a slave you're going
to be very unhappy if you just feed your
lusts you're going to be very unhappy if
you feed your gluttony you're going to
be very unhappy if you feed any of these
base desires you're going to be very
unhappy you think it's going to make you
happy and it might momentarily at least
for some period of time eventually it
doesn't even make you happy momentarily
but ultimately it will not
we lose our conception of a good life we
lose our conception of a good death we
lose our conception of everything is it
any wonder that the culture Falls to pot
speaking of changing conceptions of
fundamental things
there is a vote up in the Senate the
vote is for the quote unquote respect
for Marriage Act this is really the
abolished Marriage Act this is really
the destroy the meaning of marriage
and bankrupt Christians and Jews and
Muslims Act
the ACT would not only enshrine
obergafell the the decision of the
Supreme Court that radically redefined
marriage into law but it would
it would make it illegal for people in
in much of American public life to hold
the real view of marriage it would
basically ban the Christian Jewish
Muslim sensible normal view that
everybody held until five minutes ago
with certain carbats but not too many so
we we've got the there was a vote that
happened a little while ago 12
Republican Senators squished on it it's
very very frustrating
then there was a vote that happened last
night to advance it so now it's there's
a final hurdle today on Tuesday I urge
you call your Senators tell them to vote
against this thing tell them to vote to
include certain amendments that will at
least make this a little bit better
since they probably can't stop the whole
bill but it is worth pointing out here
I think largely the reason those
Republicans squished is because they
think it's a lost issue it's a lost
cause man move past the marriage issue
no one cares anymore we're going to lose
our voters if we come out against it
that's not true
it's a poll that just came out of a 2000
likely voters this is conducted by on
message Incorporated for the Heritage
Foundation found that voters in Wyoming
Indiana Iowa Utah and West Virginia
oppose the same-sex marriage bill not
only oppose it without the Amendments
they oppose the whole thing
47 opposed 41 support and then among
Republicans which is largely the
constituents of these squishes 70
percent oppose the bill conservative 73
strongly oppose the bill
and then here's crucial more than half
of the respondents 53 said that they
oppose the bill when they are told about
the part of the bill that would allow
for lawsuits against anyone who refuses
to participate in same-sex marriages
that number Rises to 69 among
Republicans
so people oppose the bill generally
and then when they find out what's in
the bill the real meat of the bill
they the majority opposes it not even
like there's some people undecided so
it's 47-41 no no the majority oppose the
bill do not do it one way to stop this
or to at least make it a little bit
better uh there were three amendments
put up
Mike Lee James Langford Marco Rubio
these will be held on Tuesday afternoon
final vote expected to take place
immediately following
we need Lee's Amendment okay we need
Mike Lee's Amendment I'm glad the guy
got reelected to the Senate he's already
doing great stuff call your senator
this is a fight that a lot of
conservatives say oh who cares oh what
matters it's just a minor thing guys the
slippery slope
from
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton both
campaigning on how marriage as the
sacred Union between a man and a woman
from the slippery slope from that to
then a few years later they kind of
changed their views to the normalization
of
Balenciaga s m Kitty porn photo shoots
it was really fast okay the slippery
slope goes really fast the slippery
slope from
hey let's change our understanding of
the relations between men and women and
our views of sexuality to drag queen
Story Hour and we're going to cut off
little kids genitals and put them on
puberty blockers was really really fast
okay this matters it is a political
winner actually the people are on our
side conservatives grow a spine along
with some other
anatomical features please
the word of the year
is gaslighted
the word of the year not just according
to me
and our observations according to Miriam
Webster
the word of the earth is gaslighting
what is gaslighting according to
Merriam-Webster it is quote
psychological manipulation of a person
usually over an extended period of time
that causes the victim to question the
validity of their own thoughts
perceptions of reality or memories and
typically leads to confusion loss of
confidence and self-esteem uncertainty
ones emotional or mental stability and a
dependency on the perpetrator
why is this the word of the year Well
Miriam Webster reported that the word
was looked up 1740 more this year and
there was a ton of Interest over the
course of the year
this is largely what motivates
support for Donald Trump
and for trump-like candidates and the
Trump acolytes throughout
it's the policies it's the opposition to
the GOP establishment but it's that
people have the sense that not only are
we being
abused not only are Bad actors in some
cases really bad actors and some people
in some cases like people who worship
the devil and go to Spirit cooking
dinners kind of bad people not only are
they running the show
and not only are they lying to us but
they're telling us we're crazy and
they're actually driving us and saying
oh no what are you we're not Outsourcing
your jobs no we're not flooding your
country with foreign Nationals no no
we're not doing that and that's good
that we are and no no we're not what are
you talking about don't believe Your
Lying Eyes
no the things that you're seeing
happening that's not happening there's
no creepypetto Island no no this is none
of that's happening nothing to see here
move along
Move Along
it's get it is gaslighting and it's it's
only going in one direction if the price
of your Thanksgiving meal has left a bad
taste in your mouth remember it is
completely normal to keep paying more
and more and more for the same things
right wrong that's what they tell us but
it's not true today is the last day of
the daily wire cyber sale everything in
our shop is 40 off that's right 40 off
my book's reasons to vote for Democrats
speechless controlling words controlling
mines 40 off the iconic daily wire truth
bomb and our new leftist tears dog bowl
free shipping on orders over 75 bucks a
free life to steers tumbler on orders
over 100 bucks unless you are one of the
super fans that wants to give us extra
money head on over right now do not wait
go to dailywire.com shop today
for your last chance to get 40 off our
best deal of the year on all the gifts
worth giving
speaking of Donald Trump
when people talk about the potential
Trump campaign
his niece Mary Trump who's some big lib
who's made a name for herself just
trading on her uncle's name Mary Trump
has a threat and a promise for
Republicans if they ditch Donald Trump
whether he runs pretends to run or
doesn't run he will do anything to take
down any Republican Who Dares go against
him and as he made clear a week ago uh
he's willing to dig up dirt on his
opponents including Ron DeSantis we
don't know just what kinds of
information he has on other people in
his party what we do know is that he
would be willing to use it and we I
believe we talked about this before the
2020 election uh Donald will burn
everything down if he feels like he's
going down we can't discount that so
that this is I think probably the most
astute political commentary we have ever
heard from Mary Trump
the only thing even resembling is to do
political commentary from Mary Trump
but
I think she's right about this and some
people are going to view that as a
terrible Danger
especially the more establishment type
of Republicans
and some people
such as myself
and I suspect many of you out there are
going to view this as one of the best
things about Trump
because
Trump is the honey badger and he just
doesn't care and he's just gonna he's
just gonna do he's just gonna go for it
he's not a republican he wasn't raised
in the conservative movement he's not
he's just going to do what he wants
he's going to engage in a hostile take
over the Republican party that hates him
the party leaders who hate him and this
is the probably the best selling point
for the man
if you are like me one of these people
who say you know this political
establishment is not really working for
me
and it's not working for a lot of
Americans because no matter which party
wins
we get more of the same unpopular
policies just off the top of my head the
transgender stuff the weird sex stuff is
extremely extremely unpopular and yet
both parties push it
but but look the Republicans are about
to vote they already did vote to
radically redefine marriage both parties
push it you see the quote unquote
Republican on The View who's saying it's
really terrible this anti-trans rhetoric
it's really terrible why would they call
these groomers groomers it's horrible
right so the Republicans they cave on
that
immigration immigration is very
unpopular if you look at public opinion
polls most Americans want to drastically
reduce all immigration not just illegal
but legal to both parties push for much
much more immigration these bad trade
deals very unpopular both parties push
for it the our American foreign policy
for the last I don't know 30 years
deeply unpopular both parties push for
it so if you look and on so many other
issues too
the surveillance State all the rest of
it
if you if you look at both parties and
you say neither of them are doing
anything to fix this then the bull in
the china shop looks very attractive to
you
and when the lib warns and says well if
he doesn't get the nomination if you
Republicans keep playing footsie with
Trump and he might burn the whole thing
down
the reaction of many conservatives is
going to be don't threaten me with a
good time
oh no he's gonna burn it all down oh no
don't threaten me with a good time
darling
it's the gaslighting it drives us crazy
though
a lot of this
corrosion and Corruption
it might be exposed at least some of it
Elon Musk
is promising
to not only get to the bottom
of the Free Speech suppression on
Twitter
the protection of Hunter Biden the
protection of Joe Biden the shadow
Banning of conservatives the the
outright open Banning of even the duly
elected sitting president of the United
States all of it
he's promising to make it public
he says the Twitter files on Free Speech
suppression soon to be published on
Twitter itself
the public deserves to know what really
happened
in some ways
the publishing of that information
the exposure of what the libs have done
to rig not just one little social media
app but don't forget we're talking about
the Public Square we're talking about a
self-governing republic therefore we're
talking about the whole political order
elections the time before elections all
of it
the exposure of that kind of corruption
is in many ways more valuable
than even musk reinstating some banned
accounts
it is just it will be so valuable
to have proof that we're not crazy
that those of us who have been told for
years and years oh you well you think
you're being Shadow banned oh please you
what you think you don't have rights to
please you're just crazy
and we were told that by the same people
who said well you don't want to take the
experimental vaccine for covet you're
crazy oh it's totally safe and totally
effective you're just you don't hold on
you don't you don't think that the Wuhan
virus came from nature you think it
might have had something to do with the
Wuhan Institute of virology you're crazy
hold on you think that the 2020 election
might have had some problems with it why
oh my gosh you're just crazy hold on you
think that there's a creepy Elite
pedophile cabal that meets on this
island in the Caribbean and involves
some of those prominent people in the
world you're crazy you're crazy you're
crazy
we're not crazy
we're not crazy we've got eyes we've got
ears we're seeing these things happen in
real time and so if Elon Musk
can go in and definitively say this is
what the system was doing to rig it
against conservatives
that will be extremely valuable and that
as far as I'm concerned having not
needed to spend 44 billion dollars to
buy Twitter I think it was worth every
penny of Elon musk's money speaking of
buying things and spending a lot of
money
there is a shocking figure it comes out
of an underreported aspect of the
culture War we always talk about the sex
stuff and abortion and immigration even
U.S home buyers now need to make six
figures a year to afford the medium
median home in the United States
so
the numbers have just come out according
to analysis by Redfin which is one of
the main real estate brokerages
housing prices remain fairly elevated
uh typical home prices have surged more
than 45 percent since the same time last
year
so the mortgage payment rates are about
2682 dollars right now which means the
annual salary required to afford such a
property has increased from 73 668 a
year to one hundred seven thousand two
hundred eighty one dollars a year
that's a lot of money
that's a lot of money before before
blank book success
before I had my great professional
success publishing a stack of blank
pages I wasn't making that kind of money
a lot of people don't make that kind of
money most people don't make that kind
of money
now you might say well it's just because
of inflation so therefore you know wages
are going to rise too wages aren't
Rising
average hourly wages have nominally
increased five percent over that period
so the income that you need to afford a
home went from seventy four thousand
dollars to a hundred and seven thousand
dollars
but your wages only increased five
percent
so what that means effectively is you
won't be able to afford a home and when
you can't afford a home that means that
you're not going to have that degree of
Independence you're not going to have
that degree of property we talked
yesterday on the show about how money
talks and Bs walks and it is very
important if you want to maintain
political power to have some cash okay
have some assets
because that really speaks a lot in
politics
but the
ruling class does not want you to have
assets
they want you to own nothing and be
happy this is the world economic Forum
vision of the future this is the great
reset vision of the future again I know
we all sound like crazy conspiracy
theorists but in the world of creepypeto
Island and the weird Balenciaga ad
campaign and the establishment being
wrong about
basically everything for the past two
years at least
I don't think that's so far-fetched I'm
just quoting the words of the world
economic Forum back to them
you will own nothing and you will be
happy
you will rent everything
you will eat bugs you will live in a
little pod
you will do everything virtually
you will just just zoom just go into the
metaverse just put on the headset
even our romantic relationships now are
virtual so other people texting on the
dating apps are looking at porn
marriage decreasing
marriage rates decreasing now Democrats
redefining and destroying marriage and
Republicans going along for the ride
it's just
hard not to notice these things because
to quote Andrew claven quoting Ernest
Hemingway things happen gradually and
then suddenly I think we're sort of in
the suddenly phase a lot of these things
are coming together right now
okay and it's not just even our
cultural hobby horses you know
oppositions drag queens or whatever
we're talking about real cold Hard Cash
here okay
people are being squeezed especially the
American middle class is being
squeezed and what that translates to
is a restructuring of our political
order what that translates to is a great
reset one of the most frustrating parts
of this reset
to me Beyond you know losing our whole
country and way of life
but part of that too
is that
for the first time in my life
lots and lots of people in this country
seem to care about soccer I was
scandalized by this over the weekend we
will be talking about it with Jake crane
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]